welcome back to the David Pakman show I
am Benjamin Dixon host of the Benjamin
Dixon show and host of the upcoming show
to the point which will be hosted by
Revere press Revere press calm
definitely want to check that out David
is away as he is traveling to Las Vegas
for a conference but he will be hosting
for the remainder of the week
broadcasting from Las Vegas let's get
back into the news now yesterday David
covered the firing of Kirsten Nilson the
Secretary of the Homeland Department of
Homeland Security now underneath the
firing as David discussed is the fact
that President Trump is infuriated with
the uptick in the number of border
crossings that happened in February
which is the highest number since 2011
now of course underneath that data is
quite a bit of revealing information
about what's actually happening south of
our border but we'll get to that
because Secretary Nelson pushed back
against Donald Trump's attempt to
unlawfully ask border agents to refuse
access to migrants to refuse access to
asylum seekers to turn them away at the
border several things that he was
requesting illegally
I guess Kirsten Nielsen finally got up
enough nerve to say okay I can be evil
but I can't break out right break the
law I guess that's the deciding factor
because she of course was the individual
who put families and children in cages
and separated families she was okay with
that she just didn't want to be caught
on the wrong side of the actual law
never mind
implementing unjust laws but that's an
entirely different conversation
underneath all of that is of course the
mastermind behind this we'll pull up an
image of him on the screen Steven Miller
now listen I'm not one to talk about a
person being bald because as you can see
I don't have hair but someone really
should tell this guy that being this
evil at the age of 33 actually wears you
down because he's only 33 as you can see
on the screen but now and homonyms aside
Steven Miller has had a singular focus
since he has
a part of the Trump administration and
that focus has been to cause cruelty and
pain in the lives of immigrants and
asylum seekers that sing that is his
number-one goal he is looking to
implement the most draconian policies
possible at the border and he has a
vessel in Donald Trump who's willing to
go along with it
even to the point of elia illegality
right even to the point of breaking the
law I want to read a quote from CNN so
that you can just get some context about
what's going on and and I saw this tweet
this quote first of all from nation
reporter Adam Serer and I mention him
because he coined a phrase that I think
it is so relevant here he said that the
cruelty is the point the cruelty is the
point and I think that is once you put
everything that Donald Trump does in
context of the cruelty being the point
then you understand the score right you
understand what's actually going on you
understand that you can't really
negotiate with people when the cruelty
is the point you have to get rid of them
you have to get them out of office but
this is what Adam shared via CNN he said
quote or CNN said quote according to
multiple sources the president wanted
families separated even if they came in
at a legal port of entry and worse legal
asylum seekers the president when a
family separated even if they were
apprehended within the United States
he thinks the separations work to deter
migrants from coming sources told CNN
that Nilsson tried to explain they could
not bring the policy back because of
court challenges and the White House
staffers tried to explain it would be an
unmitigated PR disaster he just wants to
separate families a senior
administration official said I mean the
cruelty is the point and while I think
it is that as a fascinating statement
and a great talking point to put this in
context it is absolutely the case Donald
Trump these are these Stephen Miller's
obsessed fixation
with with anyone with the Browning of
America let's just cut call it what it
is right Stephen Miller
Ilyn Omar got in trouble again yesterday
for calling Stephen Miller a white
nationalist well he'll his own family
members refer to him as being a Nazi
right so you know Stephen Miller has
this obsession with white genocide and
the Browning of America and too many
immigrants coming in and and and white
America becoming a minority majority a
majority minority country in this
country rather and and and so when you
think about it in context of of what
drives him you really understand and and
then actually let me take one quick
aside not only what drives Stephen
Miller but what clearly drives the
President of the United States he's not
only okay with the cruelty he's okay
with the cruelty even if that cruelty
breaks the law and so Stephen Miller has
found the perfect vessel through which
he can carry out his ideology of white
nationalism and white supremacy now Adam
Schiff said this on Twitter with regard
to Nilsson and the firing and I think
it's very important to place all of this
in context he said quote secretary
Nielsen's policies were cruel and
unconscionable a generation from now we
will still recoil at how America
separated families children from their
parents and put them in cages but make
no mistake a change in personnel is
pointless the problem comes from the
very top and that's because at the very
top of our nation we have the white
supremacists in chief Donald Trump
people always ask well why do you make
this about race because clearly this is
about stopping can we go one step
further I'm sorry it's been a while I
haven't I've been I've been working and
building companies and stuff and I
haven't had a chance to really talk
politics as much as I like to but if we
go one step further this is not just
Donald Trump people this is the
Republican Party they just don't like
the fact that Donald Trump doesn't know
how to disguise his intentions I believe
I played it here several times cuz I've
been on David show so many times I know
I played it on my show at least 20 dozen
times
but there's a clip from 2008 of john
mccain who was getting ready to run for
president and bill o'reilly is they
discussed the border and the framework
in which they discussed what's happening
at the border was literally the fact
that america is run by white christian
men and then they went on to say that
what the left and what we are you know
we radicals want is we want the
literally their words the Browning of
America why do I bring that up I bring
that up every single time I get an
opportunity to because you have to
understand that this is Republican
orthodoxy this is literally conservatism
this is what they all want they just
don't want it done in a way that can be
embarrassing to them and in a way that
it makes us so easily clear it makes it
so clear rather to every one of their
racist intentions they literally
literally fear the Browning of America
and so while Adam Schiff is correct it's
not about secretary Nielsen even though
she did unconscionable things right it's
not just about Stephen Miller even
though this is like his fantasy like
this is this is when he gets off on like
he is he is in hog heaven he doesn't
care if everything else Falls around him
as long as he can express his cruelty at
the border he is a happy man it's not
just about him it's also about Donald
Trump but it doesn't stop at Donald
Trump even though he's our current white
supremacist in chief it has to be laid
at the feet of all of conservatism a
handful of Democrats historically you
can see the videos some of the same
language but we'll get back to them it
has to be laid at the feet of Republican
Party on mass because this is what they
have been championing for the longest
time for many many years the only
problem now is that they have a buffoon
in the office in the White House who
doesn't have the ability to cover up his
white nationalism and his white
supremacy because he is an oafish
buffoon and everyone could see clearly
for who he is see him clearly for who he
is so yeah it's not just what's
happening it's not just happening - it's
not just what's going on with Neil
Miller and Trump this is America this is
a large part of America and and once we
realize that place it in context of what
my friend Adam service says the cruelty
is the point you you juxtapose those two
facts the half of America wants this and
the cruelty is the point well you see
the kind of condition that we're really
in and you see the amount of progress
that we as Americans have not actually
made it one of today's sponsors is
privacy calm slash Pakman this is a free
service that I've actually been using
myself for a while now and I love it you
just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
calms mobile app or browser extension
for Firefox and Chrome and what that
does is allow you to instantly create
virtual credit cards that are linked to
your bank account so that you're not
actually putting your real debit card
number on the Internet and you use these
virtual credit card numbers to buy
things online and with one click of a
button you have the ability to create
multiple virtual cards delete cards
freeze and unfreeze cards you can put a
limit on a card so a company won't be
able to charge you more than you
actually want them to and it protects
you from being hacked it protects you
from companies being hacked which we've
been talking about for a while on the
program and it's perfect for signing up
for free trial somewhere if you don't
want your real credit card number to be
exposed and on file and their app and
browser extension let you autofill the
virtual credit card number into the
credit card field when you're buying
things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below